some of the top features are stealth
mode which is a normal everyday Street
mode that will get you up to 45 miles
per hour in an all-electric driving for
a period of time before the engine turns
on for normal driving moving silence wow
on its own it's yeah completely silent
so orange is positive torque and green
is like regen torque so if I hit the
brakes here it's gonna think about
charging if I'm done with that or I exit
whoa it's gonna start up okay I wasn't
ready for that sorry wow I mean that
sounds incredible if I give a little
blip on the internet oh wow I mean just
to go from stealth to that it's shocking
I mean this is what everyone has been
waiting for it is yeah we didn't lose
the Brilliance of what Corvette means
but we've added something to it that's
pretty special